where are you where are you exactly
I managed to book you a slot I'm sorry
can you say that again he just announced
Lessman hats you're never gonna guess
what is oh no you're not wearing that
you look like a nun okay lastly
can't believe on xoxo it's like I'm
making up for somebody in the past life
coming in
is it Wi-Fi on the bus dude kill
yourself on the king of this kingdom is
this amazing man your whole life is
gonna change
I tell these people what to life I've
seen more DJs than you can count come
and go it is a tough business
sooner you realize that the easier it's
gonna be for you
this music means everything to me I'm in
this because I love it this is real
music it's not meant to be the
soundtrack to getting wasted or the
background to a car commercial when you
make that connection to somebody it gets
you outside yourself I always felt like
this nothing kid when I was out there in
the middle of this massive crowd I felt
like you were part of something
yeah
who's a huge party going on out there
man
the big [ __ ]
wearing this together trust me
we're gonna play an amazing set and I am
gonna be there
this is your moment you got to grab it